but like what would be because i'm
[ __ ] certain right that not just
people watching this episode but i
reckon like
every weeb living overseas yeah
probably has that dream somewhere in the
back of their head where they're like
man
i want to move to japan i want to work
in the enemies those
everyone gets them right we all get them
right so as someone who actually
made it yeah what is the advice you
would give
to people who like want to chase that
dream did the speed run round
yeah it took a year and a half i think
that's pretty fascinating
yeah yeah no no no you didn't get the
green card to prove here
i was like what no uh i mean that's the
easiest way though right i mean there's
probably guys
like i can marry again
yeah i would say learn some a lot of
like learn japanese that's like
the easiest way to get in like there's
that
jlpt where it's n1n2 or whatever and
i've heard like oh n2 is like
if you can get to n2 you can pretty much
snag like any job that's not like
two knowledgeable about
like the industry right that's like the
biggest thing
because people ask us all the time
they're like you know what's the best
way and i'm like bro i'm like
in the weirdest situation yeah this is
just me don't don't take my career path
yeah
that's a really weird career we just
want to stress we're not part of the
industry
we work with the industry we are not
part of the industry why are you asking
a youtuber on immigration law
i don't know anything you think i know
immigration though
[ __ ] dude you should because you
immigrated here i barely know how to
file my taxes
come on but like a lot of japanese in uh
like companies hiring
foreigners yes yes they do actually
quite a lot are especially in the past
year or two right they've expanded to
like the global market
people because people watching this like
write that down right now
craigslist japan knows how popular anime
is overseas that's why of course there's
like the cool japan thing
if book walker did a uh uh joe
application today
what would my cv my resume need to look
like like what are we looking for
because because because we
appoint and you can you can tell us this
because you're probably going to be like
if the job opening ever opens up
you you'd probably be the one doing the
interview right so what would
what what do you expect from someone
that's got to be on that tv
i don't know i'm not in like that team
anymore give us your thoughts
like like hypothetically because because
you you always have to hide from geeks
plus which is also very similar
in cell or something
[Laughter]
like don't be a nervous wreck so a bit
of a
charisma but a charisma yeah and have
like a social life kind of because
you got those really weird can you can
you it's a real tall order
when they when they come in do you can
like can you can you sense it straight
away oh we did some like interviews
recently actually where we're like
we did it through zoom or like right
around and like the thing
i was like looking for is like they
smile
and like i don't smile and then i also
like we asked them what's your favorite
anime series or something
and it's not the anime series they
choose it's the reason why they like it
or whatever
if they say
every application you're going to have
from now on for like every cv is just
not an in-cell
smiles in a zoom caller
i would say experience is like the
biggest thing because experience in what
working in like just anything actually
yeah
because i i i feel like that's a lot of
a lot of experience that a lot of people
are missing you know that just working
in a company environment
is is actually really valuable
experiences yeah corporate experience
definitely or if they're like fresh
graduate to at least have a few
like internships under your belt because
there's some people like
in my like previous companies i've
worked with in the past like they're new
graduates they go into the job and they
don't even know how to use excel
so if they're like familiar with all the
microsoft stuff
i mean it's it's something you never
like actively learn how to use
like excel and word but it's like such a
necessary
like skill to have working in a
corporate job yeah which is
which is knowing how to use excel it's
not on any like job application
job application but it's fun when i was
working on the bbc
i had to use excel for [ __ ]
everything i'm convinced my engineering
degree was an excel degree in disguise
because we used excel for everything
yeah yeah everything we had like
we had classes in high school that was
specifically towards excel
oh yeah so what's like the main points
right on a resume like what if there's a
three most things that you can have as a
candidate
for for applying what what what what
stands out the most
we're not talking about like don't be an
insult like apparently actually like
i'm not like the final judge no no but
just like your opinion yeah
in your opinion in your opinion it's
just like like the way they
write their like intro paragraph about
themselves
oh sure that's actually important well i
don't know for me
i read it i'm just like what do they say
like do they sound passionate or they're
just
copying pasting top 10 best ways to
write a cover letter or something oh
yeah
in japan don't have to write every uh
like letter
and like resume by hand yeah that's
disgusting oh yeah
oh so there's like what is that what is
the little job fair they do when they're
like leave school what's that called
they're they say
yeah yeah and they they can write up to
100 applications
by hand the same [ __ ] yeah i would lose
my damn
i had to do that when i was applying for
internships in japan i think i wrote
30. jesus and that wasn't nearly as as
much as some of what
like my friends did apparently they look
out for like if you care enough
and i'm like to me that just like seems
like why is this the thing that we're
caring about yeah it's like i don't
care i just want money yeah give me the
experience i'm gonna make you money yeah
shut up give me this can we just be
honest here and just say
why do you need this job because i'm
broke yeah and i just graduated
and i need the [ __ ] money okay i need
a job just give me the
give me the job [ __ ] hell i do like
it when they're extremely passionate too
like not saying like oh my god i'm like
a huge love liver and i've loved life
for everything it's more like you know i
was in a different shout out to the love
life
i would never hire someone who's
obsessed with love life
you know why because their loyalty will
never lie with you ever yeah no matter
what but you can bribe them
that's true but for how long can you get
the news
how long how long can you bribe them
finish this
ripping it because okay all right your
phone just slammed on the phone very
dramatic
but okay right let's say you know
they're they're addicted to gancha
who knows how long it is before they
they do one too many gas rules they come
and at you with a raise they want to
raise maybe yeah they've
been broke they wouldn't ask me they
would ask like the ceo for the raise
okay
how would you respond to that uh well
first i would ask
oh what have you been doing this past
year differently and like
how much have you affected this like how
much has the sales been affected by your
work
and what do you want to try doing
differently if i gave you this much
money what are you going to do
like how is it basically really going to
better your life so it's basically
another job interview
is what i'm what i'm hearing is what
i've heard
one thing i find fascinating is how the
story of like we
we all have you to thank for like this
podcast and being here in japan
because it's all a lot this is yeah it's
an awful lot of
what we've done is thanks to maelyn
she's like the brainchild to a lot of it
but like i finally just got lucky okay
but like
how did the story of geeks plus forming
come to be because you make easter oh
geeks plus is the agency that we're all
oh yeah yeah and the reason why we're
here
and the reason why we're here so like
how did how did that come about
like like a new business
contest or competition every year and
then within their like departments they
also do like
business competitions right and
the first year i decided to like submit
something in it was
the kinks boss thing oh yeah
usually well i didn't want to submit it
before because there was like where the
prize money was like this much
and then this particular year the prize
money was like this and i was like
maybe i want that money